welcome back to the j-julia podcast in
our living room by our tree it's a
special festive edition because we were
like why would we just decorate a tree
ourselves well we can do it on the
jenandtony if I'm gay so today it snowed
a lot in our living room
it was very snowy covered in sand Arctic
tundra it's an Arctic hurt kick tundra
you okay
yeah this episode of Genesis brought to
you by the skin the skin provides all of
today's top stories into a concise
wonderful newsletter in your email inbox
and it's completely free so go to this
skim that's th es ki mmm two M's comm /n
and Julian get signed up for a $250 Visa
gift card because want that right also
brought to you by lift guys start
driving for lyft really awesome company
that drew the ride-sharing company that
cares about its drivers your and all
your tips make your own hours it's
really great and when you go to lift
calm / - no - that's ly ft.com so I've
shown Julian right now you can sign up
for a 500-dollar new driver bonus cuz
you're gonna be a new driver how
exciting congratulations by the way in
advance you sleep alright so because
it's Christmas I cosplayed as an elf
today you like you and we have we're
literally just gonna decorate our tree
for a little bit and hang out with you
guys while we do it we we actually had
to get a new tree for this podcast
because my tree done lost its bottom
some people couldn't find the bottom I
take responsibility I put it away last
year Julian and my mom put it away last
year along with all the ornaments so I
don't know someone might be you know
what I was thinking what since last
year's Christmas how did that giant
clean in the garage
yeah mighta gotten thrown out yeah I
could've got thrown out so I just went
to Antarctica and grabbed this because
they have trees there no I went to
Target Julian got a little target he
texted me cuz I was like you lost the
bottom of my tree going to target and
getting this a new
she was mine from a long time ago but
like you were like do you care if
there's snow on it or not and I was like
no you want but this makes a [ __ ]
mess yeah it looks like it's I mean it
looks from the naked eye or the clothes
I notice that it's just kind of like
painted on there but now it's like caked
on there it's like sprayed but it's
something like snow spray I use cool I
like how it looks and they didn't have
anything else in stock so we're gonna
we're just gonna put some four minutes
four minutes most of all that doesn't
even have a hook somebody look at what
happened on the hook
most of these are plastic at this point
because we've learned our lesson from
having so many dogs that you just can't
have matter one yeah across it we do
have some but they're like I've looked
in that bag and they're like smashed
yeah you know yeah also if the audio is
not great we're trying to talk quietly
because we know we're wearing loved
microphones and it's not as good as a
normal podcast nice but anyway mine
already fell down hold for one better so
Jenna what is your favorite part of
Christmas my favorite part of Christmas
is probably what we're doing right now
which is like making your house all nice
and festive and cozy and like eating
good food hanging out with your family
and being in a really fun environment
which is like near accra mystery I think
yeah I think being around family is nice
house I also like the tradition we've
kind of made it going - oh my god this
is massage on it
this is troubles body massage that's
from the body massage video thanks -
that was a year ago I can't believe that
you know it's crazy to come out putting
it on there like um I was talking to you
about how I could just got the me andis
invitation for their Christmas party
yeah and I feel like I got the last
year's one like a couple weeks ago you
know
crazy it really feels like wild but
anyway what I was saying is I like our
routine of going to visit your brother
yeah sister-in-law and me my nephew for
the very first time she was just born
dead he was born dead he's just a little
guy my first nephew I've never had a
nephew only have a niece I'm very
excited
these are like all the boring like
regular ones we do have some other ones
like ones in that bag and ones in that
box you can't you see what I'm gonna do
is just hang them all right here oh yeah
I'm literally only hanging them where
the podcast can see them and then that
whole trees gonna be a mess Julie how
many we're gonna be right now here doing
switch spots it's funny I'm just
complaining there's more room over here
nah baby good why don't you get some of
the other ones I got a good one
how'd you get that's just that's a good
one regular one from Target it's good
okay when I was little my brother used
to insist on hanging all of his
ornaments like right under like the the
topper but like right at the top all in
a clump and my mom would get so mad at
him especially since a lot of them were
like super heavy why did he want to
clump them up there because he was like
these are all my ornaments they're the
most important cuz they're at the top
they need to be like front and center
yeah my mom used to yell at him she was
like seven you can't just you can't hang
all of your ornaments right at the top
and in the front plus I made it so
top-heavy here I'll get this box of fun
different ones okay I was like um the
consumer aspect of Christmas and that
sounds so shitty of me but I love things
you only not I don't like shopping I
love like hearing Christmas music in the
mall or that's pretty nice I don't know
something about it and I like really
love Christmas movies so it makes me
feel like I'm in one what's your
favorite Christmas movie jingle all the
way with homes for sale
no let's say to my face that movie sucks
so hard you know I don't think I've seen
that since I was a little kid what can
be watching this here yeah I'll watch it
jingle all the way
it's a great movie so right here we have
an ornament from my childhood that will
but like so like I said my mom and
Julian packed up all the Christmas stuff
last year's they're being helpful and
kind like all of these are ornaments
that like my mom insisted that I keep
because they're from when I was a little
kid but she smashed them all into a
garbage bag
well you know what I'm gonna sue you
allegedly I might have on the edges I
don't know it's like a year ago I
remember who put what in the bag but I I
just know that like we put them in boxes
this says a daughter is a special gift
that is me and on the other side it says
Merry Christmas daughter 1994 Julianne
you were to this ornaments almost as old
as you are damn that's crazy do you want
to hang it yeah here we have another
classic it's a furry bunny sitting in a
pink rocking chair is that from your
childhood yeah
all of these are that's why I was like
why did they get smashed in a garbage
bag you all right over there yeah I'm
okay
I'm pretty sure we got this one last
year like at Target but here you go
hanging that by the bottom so we Chi can
pull it off
okay that sounds like a good flick I
like it when she pulls up a little stuff
weed this is this weekend yeah or this
week just to catch y'all up if you've
been under a rock I was in Idaho yeah
[ __ ] one it's not [ __ ] one it's a giant
butterfly mm-hmm look at it it's like
half coming apart it's gonna smash fun
is trying to smash though do I look all
right so we just get this you're just
not hanging that lets give us one badass
get it up out of here don't put it on
top of us yes you just put it on top of
another box you know what I was like
sorry
okay go ahead
that's it here hang this one in the
bottom two so each you can get it off
it's a little reindeer what you were and
I that's the story what else we got
Julian where's all your ornaments from
when you were little I don't have any
why not cuz I don't and I was never
given I mean even if I was given
ornaments I don't think I kept them why
not I don't know because I don't know I
just didn't have any like from a really
young age yeah I didn't like super I
mean I guess we celebrated but it wasn't
like with your dad yeah but it was like
we split so it was like I celebrate
Christmas my dad honked with my mom yeah
I got double Christmases yeah that was
exciting
so like the ornament thing I feel like
it was just pretty generic ornaments
each year and like if there was any cool
ornaments it was like if I was into like
skateboarding that year I've gotten like
a skateboard on a mint or something but
like a lot of the ones you have seemed a
lot more special I don't know why this
is a Christmas ornament but it is is
anything to be a Christmas ornament have
you hang it on the tree
- Shea I think guy Yeti said that well I
talked Julien into this because he did
not have one we are a menorah y'all
doing we gonna light the menorah on the
eight days of Hanukkah
I was excited that's that's familiar to
me yeah yeah
when is Hanukkah start um I'm not sure
okay Google what is the first day of
Hanukkah December 12 so a week from
Tuesday
yeah yeah I'm excited let's light can
you light the candles and also go first
we can't wait can you sing it now really
yeah bogota night el hanout milk color
sheriff
I forget I'm doing yep this one's cool I
like it it's nice it's heavy like it
Julian
I feel like I could really hurt somebody
it's heavy oh my god don't okay um so we
went so just to catch up over to Idaho
and then when I got back I took Jenna to
we went on a date to a jujitsu
tournament which was a lot of fun I
think we can throw this [ __ ] is that it
was like let's give a nice little
close-up look it's not gonna focus but
it sort of looks like I don't know it
was the thing but here here's
VeggieTales
why don't you clip that on budget tales
is cool I think I don't know I was
little Jenna what was your experience
put it in the back somewhere watching
live Jiu Jitsu matches okay was that
cool so Julian described it as the same
as like a UFC fight and I was like no it
is it like just let me preface it normal
Jiu Jitsu tournaments like are not like
this this was like normal to determine
star in like a big you know convention
hall there's a lot of mats it's quiet
it's a lot of there's a lot of light it
seems very like if you can imagine like
a like an indoor volleyball tournament
with a ton of different games going on
once like just kind of like that like
professional quiet this one I was like
they're marketing it like it's an MMA
event meaning that it's more of like a
entertainment sort of thing it's not
quite a sporting event as much as it is
like a I don't know you'd like buy
tickets and you're you're there and
there's lights and music so go ahead
this one is older than you this one's
from 1990 is it really oh my god doesn't
say Jackie on that yes Jackie and Talia
my babysitter and my babysitter's
daughter looks like you knew Jack's back
then no Maya Jackson College okay okay
this has no way to hang it up but this
is digger on a snowshoe holding a bunch
of presents okay talk to me about yeah
Julian was like it's it's gonna be
similar to like a UFC fight and I was
like
okay I was thinking that we were going
into some like gymnasium to watch like
an amateur amateur wrestling tournament
that's what I was trying to describe
like that's what you would expect that
was totally just like waiting to go sit
in some bleachers and like watch people
choo jets around but it wasn't there was
like lights and music they had a full
stage lots of cameras camera angles it
was pretty cool I thought it was a good
event no it's really cool it looks like
if that it was at mussel farms new
headquarters in 95 why do you have so
many old [ __ ] things I don't have any
of these that's why I was like mom why
would you take down the tree and like
smush all my ornaments in your mom want
blast it's my fault
it's the Debbie mission it is how dare
you I'm gonna get the other bag of stuff
okay oh [ __ ] I don't know yeah I'm good
journalist the dogs not facing the right
way it needs to be facing guess whose
first Christmas it is bad
yeah that is it your first Christmas
sexy boy it's sexy boys first you've
been calling him a big boy he's putting
on that good winter weight you know what
I want to know what your favorite
holiday memory with me is oh cuz I know
I know - I guess I know I know Am I I
liked um the first year that we went to
Oregon and we saw the coast cuz I was
like you need to see the Oregon Coast
it's beautiful and we are out by the
ocean and we like hugs are you kidding
me that's literally what I was gonna say
no it is I swear to god I'm gonna pull
up that picture right now yeah it was so
cool I get so nauseous that that moment
but like that whole trip for me was like
so special because we met my niece for
the first time
Julianne here you go I think this might
be one of the first ones along with that
pink rattle that I showed you this one
is a beautiful safe for children nice
sharp metal ornament nice
says Jana on it and it says 1986
that's not wait so that's the year we
were born though I don't know you hang
it that one's yours
I'm trying to put a picture of us
doesn't this look like such a nice
present for a baby
Michael isn't his baby it's like in the
office when the bait one of the babies
is in the office and Creed is hitting it
like paper clips to play with like you
can't give baby papers you think it's
okay I'd so much all right let me find
this I gotta find this picture I know
that's 15 boring right now oh I found
the other one that says body the other
ornament is I thought inside I I do also
apologize to those of you that we're
looking forward to vlogmas this year
just like it ends up making the holidays
so much more stressful than they need to
be you know because it's like the only
time that I really take any time off
during the air and I'm like can't even
really fully shut off you know oh that's
that sure that's like on the California
coast
and so that trip was like really nice
for me cause like we got to meet your
niece for the first time we got to go up
the coast but like you're sick I
remember I got sick at the very end
yeah I was saying well we brought bread
with us oh yeah the same to just go we
met up with him in San Francisco and his
brother and that was something about
that it was really fun it was really
nice there's a nice trip are we going
this year yeah I got me my nephew yeah
you know are you hanging in the or who's
telling the story good pictures um what
I just gonna say I was gonna say
something a lot yeah does your family
have any like holiday traditions
I feel like ours was mostly just like on
Christmas like I'm the morning we would
wake up at my mom's house and like
sometimes we switched off sometimes I
think we would do Christmas Eve with my
dad but I was usually at my mom's and we
would wake up
I would demand to wake up at like 5:00
or 6:00 a.m. say and open presents the
second I woke up maybe and then my mom
would say okay she would probably like
to take a little nap or whatever after
we opened all of our presents by you
know 6:30 and then she would cook us
like bacon and pancakes and eggs and
stuff and we'll just sit around in our
jammies and like do nothing sounds
really nice yeah
and then later I think we'd go to my
dad's for dinner and we would open some
presents for my dad and then have a nice
Christmas dinner with him there's not a
nice it's really nice yeah you know we
did what we I woke up mad early for
presents like you did yeah
but so he would open up presents we
would always play poker we loved playing
poker did ya like me my step-brother my
brother my dad there was played poker
but we like we would watch basketball
and in the evenings you have a
basketball game no that's yours by the
way have you been training yeah big time
in the evening we would go see a movie
at the cinema that's so fun we lived
really close to most of my childhood my
dad's house was like right down the
street from in Culver City from the
cinema so we would all just kind of like
walk together
okay so honestly I think that's part of
the reason why I'm so like for a while I
was so had a min about taking into the
movies cuz it's like going to the movies
was special to me as a kid yeah I mean I
liked going to the movies but it's sort
of whatever yeah I feel my next-door
neighbor's so I used to babysit them
they were younger than me I don't know
how much younger
I think they've both graduated college
at this point they weren't like infants
yeah there were kids and so I obviously
like most of you guys know every
Christmas every birthday I would ask my
mom for a cat or a dog and it was always
know she finally folded one year I got a
ferret lived for like eight years
I think her name was Dylan I loved doing
but so my next-door neighbors it was
like the most bizarre thing they would
wake up super early like we did but they
would open one
at a time and like play with it and then
Christmas would last like three days
like I would go over there to babysit
them and they still have Christmas
presents under the Christmas tree and
I'm like what are you guys doing like
don't you want to open your presents I
like we're still playing with this one
and I'm like what [ __ ]
I mean there's nothing wrong with that
there's a lot that's way too much cases
such sweet kids like they would open
something and be so grateful and
thankful that they would play with it
like holes day and then they wouldn't
open their other presents unlike most
kids in America who like army and just
like tears through ten of them right
it's like youth oh but one year I woke
up and they had opened their first
present and it was a little shell T
puppy Shelties by the way sort of looked
like little border collies with like
different colorings but they're like
really cute size they're really sweet
and they named her pepper and I woke up
but I couldn't see you didn't have my
glasses on oh my god I hear them out
back just like giggling I'm having the
best time and I look out my window in
the snow there they are full snow gear
at like 7:00 a.m. giggling and playing
the snow with this little puppy it was
like [ __ ] mom like the targa who's got a
puppy are you kidding me mom please
please mom can we get a puppy please but
your mom is allergic right yeah we're so
she claims well my mom was two of two a
lot of things that's why we didn't grow
up right pets but that was probably the
worst and then of course I babysat them
after that and the Christmas tree
through Christmas presents at under that
tree for like three months
that's so I got the best present it was
a puppy they're not done playing with it
until she dies I thought that only
happens in movies like what people get a
puppy for Christmas right you unwrap a
box and a little furry little boy did it
the dad did it so they're like really
didn't they obviously had the puppy I
think the day before and he kept her
like in a crater like it's someone's
house or something and then they what
they got to wake up Christmas morning to
their puppy it's not so unfair yeah
I'd be jealous too it was okay she was a
really cute dog I don't know if she's
still alive
whoa well I don't that was like so many
years ago you kidding me are we not oh
here we go so we have another one from
1986 it says a baby put special magic in
holiday moments 1980s your face here's a
picture of me sleeping which is what I
do best that's cute I was a little chunk
in the face Chuck you were literally a
baby yeah chunk in the face what what's
your favorite holiday like thing to put
in your mouth um like meal or drink
anyway I really like hot chocolate I've
always been a hot chocolate fan my dad
for christmas dinner used to always make
a ham i liked Christmas ham with
pineapple it was really tasty it's
canned pineapple upstate New York I
don't know if you know this but we can't
just get some pineapple real easily
it was delicious anyways obviously don't
eat any ham anymore but it was very good
and I'd say our chocolate probably yeah
it's easy to find vegan hot chocolate I
mean not super easy but at least you
don't have to like jump through a
thousand hoops to make it yourself like
you can totally find real cocoa powder
yeah and make your own yeah
or there's ones that are vegan I don't
have dairy in them although like cheap
like Swiss Miss like those kinds all
have dairy in them which is very
disappointing so I got this a couple
thinking's last year maybe before I was
like this is like super vibes let's get
it and put it on the tree yeah that one
almost smashed this is like something
you would find on Roman columns tree
yeah it is there way to hit I want to
see their tree it's probably it's
probably a bad dude it's probably so
sick and trendy you know everything they
do is it looks cool typical like wake up
and are cool Julian what we have a
serious lack of ornaments happening up
here alright so my favorite Christmas
Neal was latkes my god oh good yes of
course it's a joke because it's a
Hanukkah meal but since I grew up my
handy son I'm primarily spending time at
my mother's house and I'm mom she's
Jewish we would eat latkes
and we would make them at home a cheese
blintzes what's in here all the diner's
that had all the walkies well most of
our town was Jewish
we were like growing up with like
takeout food wasn't really too much of a
thing for me like we were bearish don't
make everything yeah I don't know why I
really know how I go mom can we go to
wendy's for dinner and she go of course
we can go wendy's for dinner like she
would like be really sweet if I ever
asked but that was until I was like
older I don't remember ever asking when
it was a little Oh
you see lockers though you see lockers
but we would make them and my mom would
always have the best recipe because she
just like she everything she loved and
made was like delicious my mom my mom is
the reason I know how to cook and I
consider myself like a like a home cook
you're pretty good cook I owe that to my
mother you're a little dangerous I like
to stay out of your way but you I'm
working on that part I'm working on that
bird they call me dangerous lately they
call me dangerous latinus am i smart I'm
handing you my girl
what color do you want no no not that
one no one's like metal we should just
get rid of the metal ones so they don't
smash yeah we're still in Southern
California all those are the quakes
speaking of which what time is it I
don't know either because I don't have
my movement watch on I'm gonna fall down
you cannot just segue you can do it Oh
guys you've heard me talk about moving
watches before they're beautiful looking
pieces yes there's my affordable prices
guys
this is a company that makes classic
design with quality
watches and they have a number to his
house it's not just one style okay you
want to look for a specific style of
watch they have an array of them so go
to mV mt taka m / JJ which one you want
this one you know what I can't stop
thinking of up here is that vine of that
old woman playing ping pong I'm smashing
Wow Wow that's what I feel like is gonna
happen I'm gonna follow the truth okay
oh yeah yeah anyway
nvm T calm /jg gets you 15% off guys and
you get free shipping and free returns
you're not gonna want to return it
though they make great gifts they made
great gifts if you're if you need to get
a watch for your dad your mom your
sister your stepsister your stepmom your
neighbor you mail in that's a really
nice gift for your man you gotta love
your [ __ ] mailman Julie you've got uh
you got our mailman Robert uh a water
bottle I got him a nice little canister
yeah anyway guys like this these are
watches that look like they should cost
like five hundred dollars but they are
really affordable they start only $95.00
really awesome selection and you know
what sometimes you just kind of treat
yourself okay yes come here go to nvm t
calm sighs JJ get 15% off and then if
you you know want to earn some money
after spending it go to drive for lyft
cuz lift needs drivers and you are who
they want if you go to ly ft.com slash
you know Julian you can sign up for a
new five hundred dollar driver bonus
that's some Christmas cash that's some
Christmas cash some Hanukkah cash or
just in Kwon's look at and what's great
about lyft is you keep 100% of the tips
that you make within the app the the
tips are all happening in the app it's
like it's like a very awesome system
easy to maneuver on the customers and on
the drivers end which one do you want
it's good so you make 100 keep behind
sending the tips you make alright those
add up really quickly it's a really
awesome feature you make your own hours
one of my favorite parts about driving
for lyft is that you make your own outs
I think that's a really really rad thing
if you want to flip into driver mode if
you want to flip into driver mode you
got that 100 fold down there if you want
to flip in the driver mode for a couple
hours while you have some spare time it
doesn't even need to be a proper shift
like your average work shift
it's literally whatever you make it you
know if you're in your car and you have
some time you can earn some money all
right and Express pay allows you to get
paid almost instantly there's no waiting
weeks to get paid guys drivers have been
paid over two hundred million dollars
since tips were introduced to the
platform right now just get going go to
Li ft.com slash injury and get your
bonus get going you are not going to
regret it and lastly when you want to
know what's going on in the world but
you don't want to dig through piles of
nonsense on Twitter on new sites have to
pay subscriptions for sites go to the
magazine stand go to the skin they beat
everything by far and it's brave they
beat everything with how concise their
and they beat everything with timing
it's in your inbox and your email right
in the morning all right don't know
anything
that's all you I almost did
and most of this can we do two together
therefore why the skin is awesome it
really curates all the top stories the
ones that you need to know to be amongst
your co-workers with a knowledge you
need to dominate the conversation
alright no no nonsense stories no little
stories only the stories you need to
know in a concise format in your email
it's completely free go to the skin calm
that's th es ki mmm calm serene Angeline
can you sign up for a $250 Visa gift
card which you can buy probably 250 of
these with pretty awesome right that's
all our yeah so you enter to win that
gift card and
regardless you are now entered in a
database your email is gonna have great
information every morning it's this
again check it out it's awesome
it's great there's broken ones in here
I'm scared right here Oh God
is this class yeah sure look at that
[ __ ] you can't fool me - it's a joke a
joke no no don't don't actually come
here go show you the trash bag for what
I don't know it looks really nice it's
stunning really coming should we turn
off the lights for a sec yes you are
do you have any other holiday traditions
wow that looks pretty nice holiday
traditions yeah you guys can't see the
topper but it's just like a little star
that we got from Target I can show them
it's okay whoa what an interesting
podcast hopefully you guys are enjoying
this I know it's not like a ton of
talking yeah it might not be the
greatest so listen to either I don't
know but honestly though like sometimes
I just like boring conversations in my
ear like I like kind of like as white
noise you know that's why I like the
sleep with me podcasts but I also like
just the idea of having kind of a
background conversation happening mm-hmm
it's just casual it's really nice it's
nice sort of soothing you know this
little thing in your head the elf thing
yeah it's getting on your hat yeah just
getting in your element
what do you mean it's getting on my head
oh no it's from the tree never mind just
a couple of green little specks so you
want to tell what's going on
Tuesday what's going on
to say what am i doing on Tuesday Oh
Julian is playing an ATAR mantle babji
I'm competing in my first video game
tournament ever
guys I don't know if you know who shroud
is or doctor disrespects or people at
that but they're don't cut yourself on
that be careful the professional gamers
pretty much and my thinking life is
watching Shroud headshot kill my
boyfriend so basically it's called the
pub G winter charity Invitational it's a
charity tournament we're all of the
winners don't need their winnings to the
charity of choice and then it's your
choice only if you win oh the top like
five did you did you guys decide who
what your charity no don't do this we
way past the deadline way past but
there's like a lot of charities you can
pick like Doctors Without Borders and a
whole bunch of really awesome what the
hell was that
it's the quiz and this goes seriously
what was that I think it was that Pepsi
bottle coca-cola
Dhaka and so I'm gonna be streaming this
tournament and I think a lot of big
names are gonna be playing in its little
be interesting but me and Prive who is
Josh he's our mod and our friend from
twitch he's gonna be my duo's partner so
this is a whole new experience
playing competitive video games it's
pretty exciting
sadly guys he passed on the
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to have
me be his duo's partner so I did really
make a splash yes splash is exactly what
I wanted not thank you let's be honest
I'm incredible speaking of splash yes
how do you feel about the Jersey Shore
Road Trip reunion what's that
do you didn't hear about it I just saw a
reunion Trident oh so they announced
it's like the new season of Jersey Shore
is the big road trip family road trip
with Sammy not a part of this
why is that what happened behind stamp
Boron's there so what i wonder what it's
like how the format is gonna be is it
gonna be very self-aware that the fact
that they're all much older now and it's
not gonna be the same are they gonna be
really trying to force the same thing I
hope they don't try enforce I hope they
do though okay
I do not want to see like mothers of two
children going out and getting blackout
really really bad things that gives me
no pleasure sure yeah I mean I hope that
they do what they want to do and like
have fun but like I don't I don't need
to see 30 year old people getting
blackout drunk and most of them like I
think I think you're right it gives me
pretty sober at this yeah and also it
does get a little sad but like I think
there's a fine line like it can be
really entertaining if you're the right
amount of self-aware and like meta but
if you're two minute it's like okay this
is weird I feel like I'd be interested
to watch sort of the fallout of that
roller coaster you know what I mean like
if they had some real honest
conversation but like what it did to
their life and yeah I totally agree I
gotta be queit Mike was making like 5
million dollars a year and then he had
that whole court thing and lawsuit and
like yeah like if they got around the
fire and like talked hard catchers a
YouTube channel and jenni has the like a
blog I think like they're still they
have a online presence at this point and
I don't know sucky in jail I was still
on but that weird promo always comes on
I know we're watching literally is just
a picture of sick in jail
um I just be interested to hear them
reflect on like that time and what it
has done to them but then again I'm not
sure that that even is like a television
show like that I would just like to
listen to this what weather like an
adult response though what that you just
had to me like I'm like yeah that's good
you sure you're like I want to hear how
they feel about their life yeah
because we're like I don't know like the
same age it's not I know I know but it's
also like I watched Jersey Shore a lot
when I was younger when it was on and he
was like obviously hilarious but I like
I really loved the show right like it's
you know it's it's a [ __ ] show but you
love it you like sort of fall in love
with it mm yeah okay but that one that
hmm when did you get this one in the
2000 do you remember those glasses y2k
BP the maleeni never those glasses yes
of course I do come out here around
gotta be a little young for that
wait I think we've done a good job yeah
it looks really nice I mean I'd be
interested to watch it and see what it
is they're trying to you know make it
yeah I just don't want it to feel like
uh that laugh again season of Jersey
Shore was real it was a bad we're trying
to make it like the same and it comes
yes so like I was partially kidding when
I said that earlier like I want them to
force it I genuinely want it to be an
enjoyable experience but wait so they're
going on a road trip I think it's a road
trip I would love to hear the T as to
why Sammi is not gonna be yeah I'm sure
you could find you like her and Ron were
dating for Sony years after the show
like on and off it's maybe it's just
like something as simple as that it's
like just genuinely too painful for her
to be around him yeah at this point you
know yeah I don't blame you I mean I
don't blame I don't blame that thought I
like it's a good theory I feel like
that's a real thing well imagine your ex
from how many ever years ago like ten
years ago or whatever and you're just
forced to be on a reality show today
with that like why would you do that no
thank you
but then again well I think you have to
coming back like when they were broken
up and together I'm just I'm so upset
that we're not gonna get any new bride
she was like she was like one of my
favorites when I got down there like
fights and stuff it's that a lot of this
faith do it do it close to the camera
man I'm like really upset about that
Haiti [ __ ] psycho away from me
if you if you were watch some of the
pound-for-pound best couple fights in
the history of couples go re-watch like
season two he he threw her bed out the
door right because her bed her bed
we like recently rewatched though with
all of her things on it which physically
I don't know how that's possible yeah
but that's such like what a wonderful
job we did I think it looks really nice
it looks good
see I'm glad that we have all plastic
ornaments now so you don't have to worry
about anything breaking and smashing and
look at all the one the minutes we have
left over where do all these to go what
do we do with all that we have a tree
upstairs in our bedroom yeah we have a
little one we should do that let's do
that anyway hopefully flail sheets on I
can make a fire what are we gonna get ad
for Christmas I wanna get him the new
leash we got him a leash you never tried
it by the popular demand of the Internet
we did get him in here certainly we
never like tried it though no cuz he's
just so later I know he's got a weird
schedule right now he woke up at like
5:00 p.m. today just to go potty the
dogs barked to them and then he you know
scurried back into his tunnel even when
he wakes up like in the middle of his
night he takes the time to get out of
his little bed and go me this tunnel and
go potty go pee in his little potty he's
such a good [ __ ] boy so cute
anyway we so the week both the week I
think the week before Christmas is the
week we're taking off
I can't a week around Christmas well
like technically on the podcast I don't
know what day it falls on but we're
taking a week off for Christmas but we
will be around I think for two more
episodes this month yeah so we'll be
around to chat with you guys and we're
gonna have a normal podcast for the rest
of month we just wanted to do something
cool and that's it may or may not have a
guest on the podcast next week I may or
may not well I don't want to say it
because I'm not yeah but we may or may
not next week we're working on having a
guest we may or may not have mentioned
you know we may it may or may not Julian
I just have to say whatever candles that
you got at Target ten
you like them they feel so good they're
like tree smell I like really [ __ ] with
some tree scented candles yeah me too
especially since this smells like a
plastic of this face also good at first
I didn't realize that you would lit them
and when you open the tree I thought
that they like sprayed some tree smells
know is I had to accompany fake tree
really smells it's really nice really
thank you for this new tree it's better
than my old tree the other one was
smashed and broken sorry I smashed it
it's okay I love you love you Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas
hahaha if you want to watch me compete
in a pub G tournament check out our
twitch channel tomorrow night yeah I
hope tomorrow during the day it's not
Manik I hope shrouds in it and I hope
shroud kills you over and over and over
and over again it's my cake your life
come kill my boyfriend I'm just kidding
I hope you do thanks for watching I hope
you do really well about fun
it will see you will see alright guys
thanks for hanging out leave your
suggestions for a festive cool yeah
holiday podcasts in the comments and
hopefully you enjoyed watching us
decorate oh gee thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]